we gotta talk about that euphoria finale
one of the ending mean to you I so I
knew it was happening but I was actually
in Australia at the time that it was
filmed so I was invited to that but I
wasn't able to come so to just see it
all coming together was incredible and
and just to see how much hard work that
salmon's II put into that flag he plants
was wild so I can't wait to see what
season two entails
it was nice to hear her sing I know I
was like I was listening to it on set
when she comes through the kitchen and
I'm like oh that's such a good song and
I was like wait thank you and she was
like yeah it's me some notch a lot and
cool about it do you think she relapsed
I don't know yeah I don't know I feel
like it's for your own interpretation
and then we'll get the final answer I
feel like the first couple of episodes
of season 2 where do you think Jia goes
in season 2 we saw her starting to a
Rebelle a little bit a little bit yes I
feel like she will definitely evolve and
you'll see more of how she feels in her
perspective because right now she's just
like yeah absolutely sure that stays on
the sidelines but I feel like show
really come to life in season 2 so
whether she does some good things we've
got some bad things we don't know yet
storm Reid spilling on that euphoria
finale and that a Lister who's a big
fans Leonardo DiCaprio big fan of
euphoria crazy I mean the Leonardo
DiCaprio like that that's a big deal
like The Great Gatsby Leonardo DiCaprio
it's pretty cool more pressure going the
indices tune I feel like that will like
you will s up and rub us out like we
have to impress Leonardo yeah and we got
to do a good job and maybe you got to
get him to do like a guest spot hey
maybe he'll come in as like an advisor a
therapist wink wink
now if we're gonna ask you there's some
rumors out there that you're gonna be
part of the Suicide Squad what would it
feel like to be part of that amazing I
was such a big fan of the second of the
first movie so to hopefully be a part of
the second one would be incredible when
you think we're gonna get that
confirmation I don't know maybe when the
movie comes out maybe hopefully sooner
than that
we'll give us some confirmation on my
Instagram you'll see it et caught up
with the actress at varieties power of
young Hollywood event on August 6
it's incredible to be here to be honored
to be surrounded by my friends and
younger artists that are doing amazing
things it's it's just amazing to be able
to empower each other I feel like so
much where they're there we're in an
industry that tears each other down so
I'm glad to be here I love that answer
dang on you oh my god all night
[Applause]
you
[Music]